[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and in this
video we're going to be breaking down a
big spider-man no a home trailer update
i don't want to waste any of your time
so i'll keep it short but if you can
grab that like button and also hit
subscribe as we're gonna have a ton of
breakdown videos coming out on the movie
very soon we are giving away three mc
box sets to our subscribers but i'll
talk about that more at the end of the
video now it's been long thought that
the spider-man trailer will debut at
cinemacon next monday this is a massive
event for theater chains in which
studios have grand panels and show off
their new releases sony actually have a
three-hour event booked out and we now
know that they will be featuring the
spider-man no way home trailer it's
taken longer than peter parker's
daughter fix to get here and no doubt
it's been living in your head rent free
if trailer update videos were crackers
then my daughter would be fat and it
seems like forever since we've had any
actual updates on it outside of this one
however we now can confirm that the
trailer will debut there but
unfortunately this will be to cinemacon
attendees only this happened in the case
of the far from home trailer 2 and that
was shown early there before it took
months to release online the con has a
strict no electronic devices policy and
therefore it's probably not going to get
leaked unless someone there is willing
to risk kevin feige killing them however
it is good news and it does mean that we
will probably be getting a description
of what happens in the trailer almost
immediately after which i will of course
be covering the gap between the far from
home trailer debuting at the con and
then getting released online was about
six months however with no way home
still scheduled to drop in december
we'll obviously get it a lot sooner
unless sony just don't want to release
the trailer until after the movie which
who knows might be a new marketing
strategy that they do now saying all
that sony trailers tend to drop on a
monday and the week after is the 30th
which also just happens to be the same
week that chongqi is released i can
actually see the studio wanting to
promote both films together as it will
get fans to go see shongxi if they know
the trailer is attached to it and also
shong chi fans will get hit with the
trailer so it just makes a lot of sense
to promote them together now i have been
sent a brief description of the trailer
and there will be some minor spoilers
from this point in the video just in
case you want to swing out of here now
what my source dude bro trust me has
said and you know what you can actually
trust that guy as he has got a lot of
things right on the channel he said that
the trailer takes a lot of focus on
doctor strange as well as peter going to
him in the hopes of having him cast out
a spell that will erase the knowledge
that he's spider-man this includes peter
visiting the sanctum sanctorum and is
actually watching the spell play out in
full however peter is meant to interrupt
this and stipulate that he wants mj ned
and mate to still remember who he is and
this causes it to break and split the
multiverse wide open from this point
onwards several villains pop up and we
get a look at the lizard sandman and
electro for a few brief shots i've also
been told that there is a pumpkin bomb
in the trailer and that we end with a
full shot of doctor octopus appearing
apparently he says hello peter and that
just ends the trailer with our minds
being blown now as always take this with
a pinch of salt but i trust my sources
and i do think that the trailer will
definitely be along those lines as it
just makes a lot of sense from what i've
been told of the production so just to
sum up the video the trailer will be
debuting at cinemacon next week and i
imagine with the sony panel being three
hours long that we'll also see elements
of mobius and venom let there be carnage
that was delayed recently so they'll
probably want to show off some extra
footage and assure the cinema change
that it's definitely coming out i have
heard that xiangxi is premiering at the
event and again this ties it close to
the norway home trailer which won't be
available for the public spider-man is
going to be getting released in about
three and a half months so they really
need to start promoting it if they want
to hit that december deadline so for the
moment i'd say either the 30th or the
monday after would when i'd assume that
they want to get the first hook out now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the trailer what we've said in this
video so just make sure you comment
below and let me know as i mentioned
earlier we are running a competition
right now and giving away three mc box
sets on the 30th of august all you have
to do to be able the chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
what-if video in which we discuss all
our multiversal theories we've also
found out what the concept of every
episode is so definitely go check that
out right after this without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
oh
[Music]